[Música]
y
donald trump dijo que agentes del fbi
allanaron su propiedad de mar a lago en
palm beach florida el departamento de
justicia estadounidense adelante una
investigación contra el ex presidente
por mover registros presidenciales
oficiales a su propiedad tenemos reporte
desde miami
en su primer día de gobierno el
presidente de colombia gustavo petro
lanzó su propuesta de reforma tributaria
enfocada en financiar los programas
contra la pobreza un tema polémico que
desató el levantamiento social de 2021
también anunció la retoma de los
diálogos con la guerrilla de la ln
y los cocaleros bolivianos siguen
protestando en la paz y en santa cruz
contra un mercado instalado que
consideran ilegal pero que es apoyado
por el oficialismo apelando a la ley
general de coca piden ser los únicos con
un espacio para comerciar en la hoja de
coca materia prima de la cocaína
estas son las noticias de américa en
france 24 bienvenidos y comenzamos en
eeuu donde el fbi realizó un registro
amaral hago la residencia del ex
presidente de donald trump ubicada en el
estado de florida en el sur del país
conectamos con nuestro corresponsable
anthony welsch y en la florida anthony
que se sabe de esta requisa del fbi
muy buenas esas producciones que se
conocen muy pocos detalles acerca de
este allanamiento que se ha producido el
día de hoy en la residencia oficial del
ex presidente de donald trump este
allanamiento por parte de los agentes
del fbi de hecho ha sido el propio trump
quien a través de un comunicado ha
confirmado que varios agentes habían
entrado a su domicilio en busca de
formando parte de una investigación ha
dicho que esa operación policial es
innecesaria e inapropiada porque según
él él siempre había colaborado con la
justicia de eeuu de hecho el
departamento de justicia de eeuu tampoco
la casa blanca han hablado acerca de los
motivos por los que se ha llevado a cabo
esta operación en policial por parte del
fbi que por cierto don al tram ha dicho
que nunca antes había realizado un
allanamiento en un domicilio una
residencia oficial de un expresidente
pero todo apunta a una investigación por
parte de un jurado para determinar si
hubo o no una violación federal al
encontrar 15 cajas con material
clasificado en la residencia de donald
trump aquí en mara lago cuando en
realidad ese material debía pertenecer a
archivos nacionales es decir al estado a
eeuu antoni gracias a ustedes seguimos
atentos a esta noticia
en otros temas en su primer día como
presidente de colombia gustavo petro
adelantó a los dos principales retos de
su gobierno de izquierda una nueva
reforma tributaria equitativa que le
permita afrontar el gasto social
prometido en la campaña y la consecución
de la denominada paz total en el país
para lo cual anunció la retoma de
diálogos con la guerrilla de la ln
rodrigo se da no tiene los detalles
10 compromisos propuso gustavo petro
para su gobierno el día de su
proclamación en su primer día como
presidente se puso en marcha con dos de
ellos la consecución de la paz y hacer
de colombia un estado social de derecho
para el primero se reunió con su
homólogo chileno el también progresista
gabriel boric que es lo que hay en
concreto el deseo de continuar los
procesos iniciados en el gobierno
santos
y enriquecerlos esto incluye ahondar en
la paz con la extinta guerrilla de las
farc retomar la negociación con el
ejército de liberación nacional diálogos
suspendidos durante el gobierno de iván
duque y de los que chile seguirá siendo
garante y dialogar con el clan del golfo
para el segundo de los puntos el nuevo
ministro de economía anunció una nueva
reforma tributaria uno de los puntos más
controvertidos y esperados dado que la
presentada por el anterior gobierno dio
lugar a protestas masivas y decenas de
muertos a manos de la policía el nuevo
proyecto contempla recaudar 25 billones
de pesos durante el primer año
aproximadamente 5 mil 700 millones de
dólares la meta será recaudar 50
millones anuales combatiendo la evasión
fiscal
esto deberá resultar en el 172 por
ciento del pib en 2023 un promedio del 1
39 por ciento entre 2024 y 2030 y 3 cómo
se conseguirá esta recaudación son cinco
los puntos claves de la propuesta del
nuevo gobierno se limitarán beneficios
tributarios a quienes ganen más de 10
millones de pesos
habrá un impuesto de patrimonio por más
de 3 mil millones de pesos mayor control
de la evasión fiscal por la que se
pierden entre 50 y 80 billones al año
impuestos a emisiones de carbono y de
salud pública impuestos del 10% a
exportaciones de carbón petróleo por
encima de los 48 dólares el barril y de
oro por encima de los 400 dólares la
onza con todo ello el gobierno espera
reducir la pobreza en cuatro puntos
porcentuales el texto deberá pasar ahora
por el congreso donde el gobierno
entrante goza de mayoría
nuevamente las calles de las ciudades de
la paz y de santa cruz en bolivia fueron
escenario de enfrentamientos entre
productores de hojas de coca y la
policía local los choques responden al
rechazo de la asociación departamental
de productores de coca a la instalación
reciente de un mercado que consideran
ilegal y que es apoyado por fuerzas
oficialistas informe de manuel a cano
los gases lacrimógenos cubren la ciudad
de la paz en bolivia cientos de
cocaleros se enfrentaron con la policía
del país la atención aumentó por el
pedido de los manifestantes de cerrar un
mercado de hoja de coca manejado por un
sindicato supuestamente oficialista una
vez que el gobierno que solucione porque
mira vamos a sonar nos perjudica y como
vendedores ya no podemos vender nada y
por eso una vez del gobierno que es
oficial es de una vez el conflicto no es
algo nuevo comenzó a principios de
agosto cuando cientos integrantes de la
asociación departamental de productores
de coca adepcoca opositores al gobierno
del izquierdista luízar se salieron a
las calles para exigir el cierre del
mercado
aseguraban que era ilegal y que tenía el
apoyo oficialista y defendían manejar el
único mercado legítimo
la asociación apela a la ley general de
la coca se reconoce en el departamento
de la paz del mercado de la adepcoca y
en el departamento de cochabamba el
mercado de sacaba
el gobierno ha dicho que la norma no es
específica y ha llamado el diálogo en
múltiples ocasiones pero este no ha
tenido efecto en las partes encontradas
yo creo que el gobierno no puede
gobernar pues que se vaya porque está
haciendo mucho daño no sólo que el calor
a nivel nacional está dañando
en la actualidad 90% del negocio de la
hoja de coca legal en bolivia con un
valor de unos 173 millones de dólares al
año pasa por el mercado de adepcoca
bolivia podría repetir la situación de
2021 entiendo un conflicto similar dejó
38 civiles y 29 policías de libros en
méxico siguen las tareas de rescate de
10 mineros atrapados en un yacimiento de
carbón de coahuila como parte de las
labores será desplegado un dron
submarino y los rescatistas bombearán
agua fuera de la mina inundada para
abrirse paso e ingresar a uno de los
pozos a mediados de esta semana
necesitan que el nivel del agua baje
metro y medio los mineros estaban
realizando trabajos de excavación cuando
llegaron a un área continuada llena de
agua 5 lograron escapar y de los demás
no hay noticias
la vicepresidenta de argentina cristina
fernández recurso al fiscal y a uno de
los jueces que avanzan en el juicio por
corrupción en su contra acusada de
presuntas irregularidades en la
adjudicación de obras públicas cuando
fue presidenta natalio co soy
corresponsal de france 24 en buenos
aires nos dio previamente detalles en su
reporte
la vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner salió a la ofensiva este lunes
en el marco del juicio oral por la
llamada causa vialidad su defensa pidió
recusar al fiscal diego lusianni y a uno
de los miembros del tribunal el juez
rodrigo giménez uriburu el argumento es
que ellos participaban juntos que se
conocían y participaban juntos de un
equipo de fútbol amateur que competía en
un torneo que se desarrollaba en la
quinta en un predio que pertenece al ex
presidente de mauricio macri y esto es
parte de un argumento más general de la
defensa que considera que el juicio es
una suerte de persecución motivada
políticamente en todo caso
no hay resolución hasta el momento de
ese pedido de recusación pero continúan
todavía los alegatos de la fiscalía que
estaban en su cuarto día y acusan a
cristina fernández de kirchner y a otros
doce imputados de delitos cometidos en
el marco de obras viales y obras
públicas en la provincia de santa cruz
entre los años 2003 y 2015 los delitos
supuestos de los que se los acusa son
defraudación a la administración pública
y asociación ilícita todavía quedan unas
cinco jornadas para que la fiscalía
presente sus argumentos y luego será el
momento de la defensa de los acusados
que todos dicen y aseguran ser inocentes
sigue en france 24 y en france 24 punto
com para la ampliación de ésta y de
otras noticias
[Música]